[Musique]
j'avais justement quelques un article
dans une revue psychologique ou qui
disait vous êtes vous donner une
définition de vous-même vous disais nous
sommes des homos sensuel drapé atta je
sais pas je crois c'est igor qui écrit
ça oui c'est moi qui aie et kaki avec
les siens quelque part parce que
d'ailleurs c'était pas ce n'était pas
une interview c'était un je crois que
c'était un texte qu'il a écrit et en
fondant un texte on peut toujours aller
vers des informations plus subtil plus
sensible plus fine en tout cas que que
la parole lorsque elle vole comme ça et
que quel que soit le vous emporte au
delà du sens en réalité quand je dis aux
mots sensuel c'est très simple on sent
la même chose c'est leur style grec au
mot sensualité ça veut dire que bon deux
jumeaux ressentent exactement la même
chose au même moment ce sont des êtres
qui sont tout à fait particulier parce
que ils ont bénéficié d'une expérience
de vie commune ils ont bénéficié d'une
histoire commune connaissent les mêmes
gens et finalement le réactions sont
fondées sur les mêmes principes et à
partir de là donc vous êtes scission du
monde sont les maires général vous
tombez sur une femme
en tout cas vous dites que vous
ressentez les choses en même temps on
verra tout à l'heure
l'effet que 500 propositions oui alors
je voudrais donc les bogdanoff ont cessé
temps x et de nombreuses émissions ce
sont de nombreux de nombreux livres que
vous avez écrit vous êtes les rois de la
science fiction est justement tf1
réserve à vos cadeaux c'est un projet
qui voiture va faire parler grichka
aller allons-y attendu mort on va voir
si j'ai la même voie qu'igor ilan une
voix un peu plus grave que moi non
effectivement nous avons depuis
longtemps sur tf1 le privilège d'exercer
cet élargissement de la conscience
autour des futurs autour de la
prospective de la science aaas peyrat et
nous avons pris un petit peu de recul
ces temps ci pour réfléchir à ce que
pourrait être un renouveau n'ont pas de
panique ce qu'on fait jamais deux fois
complètement les mêmes choses même quand
on est 2 mai aux dépens en tout cas de
cette même mission et c'est à partir de
maintenant que nous nous sentons prêts à
faire partager à d'autres à tous ceux
qui nous ont suivis pendant des années
et qui vous suivront j'espère pendant de
nombreux siècles encore cette passion
que nous avons pour la découverte du
monde de demain et puis aussi la
découverte des merveilles des mystères
des charmes qui sont attachés au monde
d'aujourd'hui puis quand je vois tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui se profile dans le
monde scientifique dans tous ceux qui au
fond fascine ce grand public je pense
qu'il est absolument nécessaire de le
faire partager ça à d'autres alors nous
allons effectivement prendre une mission
générale de tir et de conseil au sens le
plus large du terme qui touche la
science la prospective un tout petit peu
aussi de fiction scientifique ou de
science fiction comme on voudra et qui
permettra donc à tout un chacun de se
familiariser avec ces vastes secteurs je
crois que c'est important aussi dans une
mission de rééquilibrage de la
télévision la télévision est une boîte à
images fascinantes parfois elle a
tendance à exagérer un petit peu trop
vers le ce que j'appelle au
divertissement populaire au sens le plus
superficiel du terme et il faut aussi
comprendre que le grand public a besoin
de services issus de cultures et de
chaîne culturelle assez alors venez chez
nous
[Musique]